Millions of people in the United States have experienced a serious mental illness such as schizophrenia, bipolar disorder, or major depressive disorder. Among the many challenges these people face are the stigma and misunderstanding surrounding these illnesses, including the idea that serious mental illness is untreatable and that recovery is impossible, as well as the stereotype that people with serious mental illness are violent or dangerous. But in reality, researchers have found that with the right, treatment, many people with serious mental illness can manage their symptoms, return to work or school, and recover and rebuild their lives. So how much progress have we made in recent decades in treating serious mental illness?
在美国，数百万人经历过严重的精神疾病，如精神分裂症、双相情感障碍或重度抑郁症。这些人面临的诸多挑战中，包括围绕这些疾病的污名化和误解，例如认为严重精神疾病无法治愈、无法康复，以及认为患有严重精神疾病的人具有暴力倾向或危险性的刻板印象。但事实上，研究人员发现，通过正确的治疗，许多患有严重精神疾病的人能够控制症状、重返工作岗位或学校，并恢复和重建他们的生活。那么，近几十年来，我们在治疗严重精神疾病方面取得了多大进展？
What are the biggest challenges in the field? What's the role of psychosocial interventions versus medication in treatment? What role can family support, work, and community play in people's recovery? How does stigma surrounding serious mental illness affect people's treatment and recovery? And finally, is there really a connection between violence and mental illness? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
该领域面临的最大挑战是什么？在治疗中，心理社会干预与药物治疗的作用分别是什么？家庭支持、工作和社区在人们的康复中能发挥什么作用？围绕严重精神疾病的污名化如何影响人们的治疗和康复？最后，暴力与精神疾病之间真的存在联系吗？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
My guest today is Dr. Kim Muser, a clinical psychologist and professor at the Center for Psychiatric Rehabilitation at Boston University. He's a clinician and researcher who studies treatment for serious mental illnesses, including illness management and recovery, specialty care programs for first episode psychosis, and vocational rehabilitation. He's the co-author of more than 10 books and treatment manuals and has published numerous peer-reviewed journal articles and book chapters. His work has been funded by grants from the National Institute of Mental Health and the Substance
我今天的嘉宾是波士顿大学精神病康复中心的临床心理学家兼教授金·穆瑟博士。他是一位研究严重精神疾病治疗的临床医生和研究员，研究领域包括疾病管理与康复、首发精神病专科护理项目以及职业康复。他是10多本书籍和治疗手册的合著者，并发表了大量同行评审的期刊文章和书籍章节。他的工作得到了美国国家心理健康研究所和物质
Abuse and Mental Health Services Administration. Dr. Muser, thank you for joining me today. Thanks very much. I'm delighted to be here. Let's start by defining the term serious mental illness. illness, what disorders does the term encompass? How common are they and what makes them serious as compared with other mental illnesses? So a serious mental illness is defined as a mental illness in which the impact of the disorder on the person's life is profound and long term. When I say the
滥用与心理健康服务管理局的资助。穆瑟博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。让我们先来定义一下“严重精神疾病”这个术语。该术语涵盖哪些疾病？它们有多普遍？与其它精神疾病相比，是什么让它们变得“严重”？严重精神疾病被定义为一种对个人生活产生深远且长期影响的精神疾病。当我提到
impact on their life is profound and long term, I'm talking about their ability to work or to go to school to fulfill other role obligations, such as being a parent, their ability to have good, ongoing and rewarding relationships with others, and their ability to take care of themselves. People who have a major mental illness that disrupts these areas of functioning for significant period of time are said to have a serious mental illness, sometimes also referred to as a severe mental illness. The most common of these different mental illnesses are schizophrenia and schizoaffective disorder, bipolar disorder, major depression, especially treatment refractory major depression that doesn't respond so well to medications.
对生活的影响是深远且长期的，我指的是他们工作或上学、履行其它角色义务（如为人父母）、与他人建立良好、持续且有益的关系，以及照顾自己的能力。患有严重精神疾病并导致这些功能领域在相当长一段时间内受到破坏的人，被认为患有严重精神疾病，有时也称为重度精神疾病。这些精神疾病中最常见的是精神分裂症和分裂情感性障碍、双相情感障碍、重度抑郁症，尤其是对药物反应不佳的难治性重度抑郁症。
And there are many other possible disorders such as post-traumatic stress disorder and obsessive compulsive disorder that may be serious mental illnesses for some people. So serious mental illness has been with us pretty much throughout human history. In the bad old days, we locked such people away, often for their entire lives. And not that long ago, treatment for SMIs, as we call them, might have included insulin comas, electroshock treatments, and lobotomies. How much progress have we made in recent decades in understanding how to treat serious mental illness? Because we don't do a lot of these things anymore.
还有许多其它可能的疾病，如创伤后应激障碍和强迫症，对某些人来说也可能是严重精神疾病。严重精神疾病几乎贯穿了整个人类历史。在过去糟糕的日子里，我们经常把这些人关起来，有时甚至关一辈子。就在不久前，我们所称的严重精神疾病（SMI）的治疗方法可能还包括胰岛素休克疗法、电击治疗和脑叶切除术。近几十年来，我们在理解如何治疗严重精神疾病方面取得了多大进展？因为我们现在已经不再做很多这类事情了。
Right. I'm glad you asked those questions, Kim. First, I forgot to mention that about 5% of the population has a serious mental illness. So these are pretty common disorders, and that often can lead to the need for disability entitlement, such as Social Security, disability income, and the like. You mentioned a number of treatments that have gone out of phase, such as lobotomy and insulin comat therapy. And in fact, there's been huge advances in both the pharmacological treatment of serious mental
没错。很高兴你问这些问题，金。首先，我忘了提到大约5%的人口患有严重精神疾病。所以这些疾病相当普遍，这往往会导致人们需要申请残疾福利，如社会保障残疾收入等。你提到了许多已经被淘汰的治疗方法，如脑叶切除术和胰岛素休克疗法。事实上，在严重精神
illnesses, as well as the psychosocial treatment, the development of therapies and rehabilitation programs designed to help people manage their symptoms more effectively and get back to living life, including work and having rewarding relationships. I would like to mention one of the treatments that you described has made a huge amount of progress over the last 50 years, and is now actually a recommended treatment, and that is electroconvulsive therapy is, in fact, a recommended treatment generally for people who have treatment-resistant major depression. It is occasionally used for a number of other conditions that we don't need to go into a lot of detail now, but the research actually shows that
疾病的药物治疗以及心理社会治疗方面，已经取得了巨大的进步，包括开发旨在帮助人们更有效地管理症状并回归生活（包括工作和建立有益的人际关系）的疗法和康复项目。我想提一下，你所描述的治疗方法中，有一种在过去50年里取得了巨大进步，现在实际上是一种推荐的治疗方法，那就是电休克疗法（ECT）。事实上，它通常被推荐用于患有难治性重度抑郁症的人。它偶尔也用于其它一些我们现在不需要详细讨论的情况，但研究实际上表明
people who have treatment refractory major depression, by that, meaning that they have a case of major depression, which has not really responded well to pharmacological treatments, that for these individuals, ECT can be a lifesaver. It can lead to both a resolution and improvement in the depressive symptoms, and it's actually been found to prevent subsequent hospitalizations. And so it's important for people to recognize that there is a role to play for ECT, as well as to know that the methods for administering ECT, which are always done on a voluntary basis, make the procedure both very, very safe as well as not harmful in terms of causing pain and discomfort to individuals. So I do think it's important for people to recognize that there's a role for ECT to play now
对于患有难治性重度抑郁症的人，即那些对药物治疗反应不佳的重度抑郁症患者，电休克疗法可以成为救命稻草。它可以使抑郁症状得到缓解和改善，并且已被发现可以预防随后的住院治疗。因此，人们认识到电休克疗法的作用非常重要，同时也需要知道，电休克疗法的实施方法（始终是在自愿的基础上进行的）使得该程序非常安全，并且不会对个人造成疼痛和不适。所以我确实认为，人们认识到电休克疗法现在的作用非常重要，
and that the methods have improved very much, although there still is a problem. in terms of people lacking access to ECT for treatment, refractory depression. A lot of us have that searing image of electroshock therapy that was used in one flew over the cuckoo's nest, the film. Is it still like that? First of all, it's always voluntary. And of course, in one flew over the cuckoo's nest, it was used as a type of punishment. Second of all, the typical procedures involve providing the person with some anesthesia so that they're not actively conscious during the time that the electric shock is provided. In addition, extensive research on ECT has shown that it can be provided with really minimal cognitive side effects associated with it.
而且这些方法已经有了很大改进，尽管仍然存在一个问题，即人们缺乏获得电休克疗法来治疗难治性抑郁症的机会。我们许多人对电影《飞越疯人院》中使用的电击疗法有那种令人痛苦的印象。现在还是那样吗？首先，它始终是自愿的。当然，在《飞越疯人院》中，它被用作一种惩罚手段。其次，典型的程序包括为患者提供一些麻醉，这样他们在进行电击时不会处于清醒状态。此外，对电休克疗法的广泛研究表明，它可以在极小的认知副作用下进行。
Sometimes there are some temporary side effects, but generally they go away pretty quickly. And often people's cognitive abilities actually improve after ECT because their depression lifts. And we know that when people are depressed, their thinking is often not. as logical and as fluid as it could be. What do we know about the role of medication versus some of these other types of treatments for serious mental illness? Are both necessary or can medication alone, for example,
有时会有一些暂时的副作用，但通常很快就会消失。而且，人们的认知能力往往在电休克疗法后有所改善，因为他们的抑郁情绪减轻了。我们知道，当人们抑郁时，他们的思维往往不像平时那样逻辑清晰和流畅。关于药物治疗与其它类型的严重精神疾病治疗方法的作用，我们了解多少？两者都是必要的吗？或者，例如，仅靠药物治疗
treat SMI? Probably for most people, medication alone is insufficient for treating a serious mental illness. There certainly may be some individuals where medication is really all they need to get back to living their day-to-day lives. But for the larger majority of individuals with a serious mental illness, medication can reduce the burden of symptoms, and it could also reduce the chances of a person having a relapse of symptoms. But it can't help them relearn life skills or help them reconnect with jobs, school, and other kinds of important functions that perhaps they were playing before in their lives.
能治疗严重精神疾病吗？对于大多数人来说，仅靠药物治疗可能不足以治疗严重精神疾病。当然，有些人可能只需要药物就能恢复日常生活。但对于绝大多数患有严重精神疾病的人来说，药物可以减轻症状负担，也可以降低症状复发的几率。但它无法帮助他们重新学习生活技能，也无法帮助他们重新找回工作、学校以及他们生活中可能曾经扮演过的其它重要角色。
And so that's where the role of psychosocial treatment comes in. in, which is helping people whose symptoms are under control. It could be that the symptoms are either in remission or that they are less severe than in an exacerbated state, learn new skills and get on with the business of living, whether it's going to school or work or parenting and just enjoying good social relationships. Can people with SMI recover completely, or do they have to continue medication and other therapeutics for the rest of their lives? Well, that's a very interesting question because it kind of gets to what do we mean by recovery? It used to be that recovery was very conventionally defined in medical
这就是心理社会治疗发挥作用的地方，即帮助那些症状得到控制的人。症状可能处于缓解期，或者比恶化状态时较轻，帮助他们学习新技能并继续生活，无论是上学、工作、为人父母，还是仅仅享受良好的人际关系。患有严重精神疾病的人能完全康复吗？还是他们必须终身服用药物和进行其它治疗？嗯，这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为它触及了我们所说的“康复”到底是什么意思。过去，康复在医学上被非常传统地定义，
terms, meaning that a person was recovered if they didn't have any symptoms of the illness anymore or related impairments. But over the last 20 to 30 years, the concept of recovery has really been redefined to make it something more personally meaningful to individuals who have a serious mental illness. And so recovery now refers to getting on with the process of living one's life and being able to live and participate in one's communities, being able to work, to have social relationships and the like, despite potentially having ongoing symptoms or challenges related to a mental illness. So the idea of recovery has been reconcernation. conceptualized to refer to recovery in terms of living a meaningful and rewarding life for the individual,
意味着如果一个人不再有任何疾病症状或相关损伤，就视为康复。但在过去20到30年里，康复的概念已经被重新定义，使其对患有严重精神疾病的个人具有更具个人意义的内涵。因此，现在的康复指的是继续生活的过程，能够生活并参与社区活动，能够工作，拥有社会关系等，尽管可能仍有与精神疾病相关的持续症状或挑战。所以，康复的概念已被重新构思，指代对个人而言过上有意义和有价值的生活，
even if they may have some continued challenges related to the mental illness. So from that perspective, recovery is possible, even though a person may continue to have symptoms or take medication for a mental illness. At the same time, to get back to the medical definition of recovery, like not having any more symptoms or any more impairments. It certainly is possible. In fact, we know that people do recover from mental illnesses across the lifespan. For some people, it takes many, many years. For other people, it can happen after just a few years or even a single episode or two. And so there are people who may end up stopping taking medication, not needing it anymore, and no longer having any symptoms
即使他们可能仍有一些与精神疾病相关的持续挑战。从这个角度来看，康复是可能的，即使一个人可能继续有症状或服用精神疾病药物。同时，回到医学上的康复定义，即不再有任何症状或损伤，这当然也是可能的。事实上，我们知道人们确实可以在整个生命周期中从精神疾病中康复。对有些人来说，这需要很多年。对另一些人来说，这可能发生在短短几年后，甚至是一两次发作之后。因此，有些人最终可能会停止服药，不再需要它，也不再有任何症状
revisit them. And this can happen either earlier in the course of the illness or later on in the course of the illness. So medical recovery is also possible. Now, one of your main areas of research is treatment for first episode psychosis, especially using something called coordinated specialty care. Why is early treatment like this so important and what does it involve? So early treatment of psychosis or early treatment of schizophrenia refers to when you try to provide treatment as soon as possible after the characteristic symptoms of psychosis have been identified. This is often referred to as first episode psychosis. And to be specific, it really means first episode non-affective psychosis. When I say non-affective psychosis, we're talking about when the first symptoms of psychosis,
复发。这种情况可能发生在疾病过程的早期，也可能发生在后期。所以医学上的康复也是可能的。现在，你的主要研究领域之一是首发精神病的治疗，特别是使用一种称为“协调专科护理”的方法。为什么这样的早期治疗如此重要？它涉及什么？精神病的早期治疗或精神分裂症的早期治疗是指在识别出精神病的典型症状后，尽可能快地提供治疗。这通常被称为首发精神病。具体来说，它实际上是指首发非情感性精神病。当我提到非情感性精神病时，我们指的是当精神病的首发症状，
such as hearing voices or having delusions, occur in the absence of the person having a significant mood disorder or mood symptoms such as major depression or such as a manic episode. When people have a major depression, thoughts of worthlessness, feeling like life is not worth living, depression, loss of appetite, or things like that, or when a person is in the midst of a manic episode in which they may have a great decreased need for sleep, they may have grandiosity, they may pursue things relentlessly, without really thinking them through. During the height of one of these mood episodes, it's very common for people to have psychotic symptoms. And so if the mood episode is treated,
如听到声音或产生妄想，在个人没有重大情绪障碍或情绪症状（如重度抑郁症或躁狂发作）的情况下发生时。当人们患有重度抑郁症、有无价值感、觉得生活不值得过、抑郁、食欲不振等，或者当一个人处于躁狂发作期间，他们可能对睡眠的需求大大减少、有夸大感、可能不假思索地执着于某事。在这些情绪发作的高峰期，人们出现精神病症状是非常普遍的。因此，如果情绪发作得到治疗，
either major depression or bipolar disorder, those psychotic symptoms usually go into remission. When we're talking about first episode of psychosis, we're talking about people who experience psychotic symptoms, like hearing voices and delusions, but they're not experiencing these symptoms in the midst of a mood episode like mania or depression. So first episode psychosis usually reflects the beginning of the illness of schizophrenia. When it's in the first six months of a person developing the symptoms and becoming impaired, the name of the disorder is called schizophreniform disorder. It's considered a schizophrenia spectrum disorder. And then after six months, If symptoms continue and to some extent impairments continue, then the person may meet criteria for either schizophrenia or the related disorder of schizoaffective disorder.
无论是重度抑郁症还是双相情感障碍，这些精神病症状通常会进入缓解期。当我们谈论首发精神病时，我们指的是那些经历精神病症状（如听到声音和妄想）的人，但他们并不是在躁狂或抑郁等情绪发作期间经历这些症状。因此，首发精神病通常反映了精神分裂症疾病的开始。在一个人出现症状并变得功能受损的前六个月内，该疾病的名称被称为精神分裂样障碍。它被认为是一种精神分裂症谱系障碍。六个月后，如果症状持续存在，且在某种程度上功能受损持续存在，那么该人可能符合精神分裂症或相关疾病分裂情感性障碍的标准。
Schizoaffective disorder is a little bit like schizophrenia, but it means the person also has significant episodes of either mania or depression in addition to the other schizophrenia symptoms. So the reason why it's so important to intervene early and comprehensively in people who develop a first episode of psychosis is that the disorder tends to develop relatively early in either late adolescence or early adulthood. Typical onset occurs sometime between the ages of 16 and 17 up to around, say, 35, although it certainly can develop even after the age of 35, even into once four. 40s and 50s. But because it's not that common a disorder, the prevalence of schizophrenia is around 1% in the general population, it is often missed by clinicians and by family members and by people in the medical profession because they don't understand what psychosis is and they don't recognize when a person is having psychotic symptoms. Interestingly, this can occur even for people who are receiving mental health treatment from a mental health professional because the mental
分裂情感性障碍有点像精神分裂症，但它意味着除了其它精神分裂症症状外，患者还会有明显的躁狂或抑郁发作。因此，对出现首发精神病的人进行早期和全面的干预之所以如此重要，是因为该疾病往往在青春期后期或成年早期相对较早地发展。典型的发病时间通常在16、17岁到35岁左右，尽管它当然也可能在35岁之后，甚至在40多岁和50多岁时发展。但由于它不是一种常见的疾病，精神分裂症在普通人群中的患病率约为1%，因此它经常被临床医生、家庭成员和医疗专业人员忽略，因为他们不了解什么是精神病，也不认识到一个人何时出现精神病症状。有趣的是，这种情况甚至可能发生在正在接受心理健康专业人员治疗的人身上，因为心理
health professional may not be aware that they have developed psychotic symptoms if they haven't done the appropriate screening. So what happens is that people sometimes go for extended periods of time before their psychotic symptoms are recognized and before they're treated. And the problem with this is that the longer you go before providing treatment for a first episode of psychosis, the more difficult it is to treat it once the person comes into treatment, and the more problematic outcomes there may be before the person gets into treatment. So, for example, it's possible for people to commit suicide before they ever get into treatment for a first episode of psychosis, and in that case, suicide could have been prevented. Or sometimes what happens is that a person
健康专业人员如果未进行适当的筛查，可能不会意识到他们已经出现了精神病症状。因此，人们有时会在精神病症状被识别和治疗之前经历很长一段时间。问题在于，首发精神病在提供治疗前拖延的时间越长，一旦患者进入治疗，治疗就越困难，且在患者进入治疗前可能会出现更多的问题后果。例如，人们可能在接受首发精神病治疗之前就自杀了，在这种情况下，自杀本是可以预防的。或者有时发生的情况是，一个人
may become delusional and they may become paranoid, for example, and they may do harm to other people because of their psychotic symptoms. And that harm could be prevented if the first episode of these symptoms were detected and treated. So in addition to preventing the harm from occurring when the symptoms of psychosis are not treated, the other thing is that we know for many people, schizophrenia can last a significant period of time, sometimes a lifetime. And so the earlier we can provide effective and comprehensive treatment, the more opportunity we have for helping people develop coping skills, skills for preventing relapses, the more we can help them develop the kind of skills for having good, rewarding interpersonal relationships, for providing the supports
可能会产生妄想并变得偏执，例如，他们可能会因为精神病症状而伤害他人。如果这些症状的首发被发现并得到治疗，这种伤害是可以预防的。因此，除了防止精神病症状未得到治疗时发生的伤害外，另一件事是，我们知道对于许多人来说，精神分裂症可能会持续很长一段时间，有时是一辈子。因此，我们越早提供有效和全面的治疗，我们就越有机会帮助人们发展应对技能、预防复发的技能，我们就越能帮助他们发展建立良好、有益人际关系的技能，为
for returning to school and work, and in effect, getting on with a business. of living. So the first episode of psychosis represents an opportunity to intervene early in the long-term course of schizophrenia with the potential of improving the long-term trajectory of the disorder, in terms of both disability, as well as improving equality of life of individuals. You mentioned employment a moment ago, and I know you've written about the importance of helping people with serious mental illness find employment. What role does meaningful work play in recovery? Now, that is one of my favorite questions, because meaningful work is potentially one of the most important parts of the recovery process.
重返学校和工作提供支持，实际上，继续生活。因此，首发精神病代表了一个在精神分裂症长期病程中早期干预的机会，有可能改善疾病的长期轨迹，包括残疾方面，以及提高个人的生活质量。你刚才提到了就业，我知道你写过关于帮助严重精神疾病患者寻找工作的重要性。有意义的工作在康复中起什么作用？这是一个我最喜欢的问题，因为有意义的工作可能是康复过程中最重要的部分之一。
People used to think that everything else needed to be under control and in perfect shape before you could help a person get a job or perhaps return to school. But now we realize that, first of all, people are capable of working, and in fact that work has beneficial effects, even if they may continue to have particular symptoms or cognitive challenges. And that working provides a sense of meaning and integration into one's community and occupies people's time in a meaningful and purposeful fashion that is both beneficial in terms of the person's self-esteem, in terms of improving, their financial standing. And we now know that helping people get jobs can actually offer them a certain protection against relapses and re-hospitalizations. And the reason is that, or one of the reasons, is that when people work, it structures their time in a meaningful sort of way. And we know that lack of structure can be stressful for everyone, and especially somebody with a major mental illness, the lack of structure can play havoc in terms of contributing to a worsening of symptoms.
人们过去认为，在帮助一个人找工作或重返学校之前，其它一切都需要得到控制并处于完美状态。但现在我们意识到，首先，人们是有能力工作的，事实上，即使他们可能继续有特定的症状或认知挑战，工作也具有有益的效果。工作提供了一种意义感和融入社区的感觉，并以一种有意义和有目的的方式占据了人们的时间，这在提高个人自尊、改善财务状况方面都是有益的。我们现在知道，帮助人们找到工作实际上可以为他们提供某种防止复发和再次住院的保护。原因在于，或者原因之一是，当人们工作时，它以一种有意义的方式构建了他们的时间。我们知道，缺乏结构对每个人来说都可能是压力的来源，尤其是对于患有严重精神疾病的人来说，缺乏结构可能会导致症状恶化。
So helping people occupy their time in meaningful ways can actually reduce that sort of stress. Let's talk for a minute about family. I'd like to know what you believe the role of family is when a relative or a spouse develops a serious mental illness. What should a family member do if they see someone who seems to be developing? a serious mental illness. Family members have an absolutely critical role to play, both in the identification of mental illnesses, as well as helping a loved one cope with and live a fulfilling life after they've developed mental illness. If we go to the beginning, family members are usually
因此，帮助人们以有意义的方式占据时间实际上可以减轻那种压力。让我们谈谈家庭。我想知道你认为当亲属或配偶患上严重精神疾病时，家庭的作用是什么？如果家庭成员看到有人似乎正在发展出严重精神疾病，他们应该怎么做？家庭成员在识别精神疾病以及帮助亲人应对疾病并在患病后过上充实的生活方面，发挥着至关重要的作用。如果我们从头说起，家庭成员通常是
the first person to recognize when a person is experiencing mental health challenges. And in fact, we know if we talk about first episode of psychosis, that about 70% of the people brought in for treatment for a first episode of psychosis are brought in by family members. So family members are on the front line of recognizing when loved one is having a difficulty. Sometimes mental illnesses involve a loss of insight or awareness that one is not functioning as well or that one has a condition that may in fact be treatable. And so family members often play a role in helping a loved one get into treatment and can have an important role to play in supporting their involvement in treatment as well.
第一个发现某人正在经历心理健康挑战的人。事实上，如果我们谈论首发精神病，我们知道大约70%被带去接受首发精神病治疗的人是由家庭成员带来的。因此，家庭成员处于识别亲人遇到困难的第一线。有时精神疾病涉及缺乏洞察力或意识，即一个人没有意识到自己的功能不如以前，或者自己患有一种实际上可能可以治疗的疾病。因此，家庭成员通常在帮助亲人接受治疗方面发挥作用，并且在支持他们参与治疗方面也能发挥重要作用。
That's one of the reasons why treatments for people with serious mental illness frequently involve a family component. Sometimes this is referred to as family psychoeducation. And it refers to when a mental health professional usually a member of the client's treatment team, engages and works with the family, including the client with the mental illness, to help them understand more about the nature of the mental illness and the principles of its treatment, as well as to reduce stress in the family, such as by teaching or improving communication and problem-solving skills. This enables family members
这就是为什么针对严重精神疾病患者的治疗经常涉及家庭部分的原因之一。这有时被称为家庭心理教育。它指的是心理健康专业人员（通常是患者治疗团队的一员）与家庭（包括患有精神疾病的客户）接触并合作，帮助他们更多地了解精神疾病的本质及其治疗原则，并减少家庭压力，例如通过教授或改善沟通和解决问题的技能。这使得家庭成员
to be allies of the client's treatment team and to work in concert with the treatment team in helping the client work towards and achieve personal goals. It would appear that many people who are living with serious mental illness are living in poverty. Those of us who live in major cities often encounter homeless people who seem to be suffering from some kind of delusion or other serious mental illness.
能够成为客户治疗团队的盟友，并与治疗团队协同工作，帮助客户朝着个人目标努力并实现目标。看起来许多患有严重精神疾病的人生活在贫困中。我们这些生活在大城市的人经常遇到似乎患有某种妄想症或其它严重精神疾病的无家可归者。
What is the relationship between poverty and SMI? There's an important and a complex relationship between poverty and serious mental illness. First of all, we know that before a person develops a serious mental illness, higher levels of poverty contribute to or increase the vulnerability of an individual to developing a mental illness. So, for example, we know that an individual who was brought up in a household in which there was a lack of economic means. And in addition, where there are higher rates of trauma, poor living conditions, and the like, are more prone to developing mental illnesses in the first place. So some of the poverty that comes from mental illness may actually be the contribution of poverty to developing a mental health condition. Second of all, we know that one of the defining characteristics of a serious mental illness is the difficulty or inability to work and therefore to have an income to support oneself.
贫困与严重精神疾病之间有什么关系？贫困与严重精神疾病之间存在着重要且复杂的关系。首先，我们知道在一个人患上严重精神疾病之前，较高水平的贫困会促成或增加个人患精神疾病的脆弱性。例如，我们知道在一个经济匮乏的家庭中长大的个人，此外，如果那里有更高比例的创伤、恶劣的生活条件等，他们本身就更容易患上精神疾病。因此，精神疾病带来的一些贫困实际上可能是贫困对患上心理健康状况的贡献。其次，我们知道严重精神疾病的一个定义性特征是工作困难或无法工作，因此没有收入来维持生计。
And that leads people to become dependent upon a disability programs to cover basic living. But these disability programs rarely provide sufficient funds for a person to really be able to have a decent quality of life. And for that reason, people with serious mental illness often live in poverty. Other factors can contribute to problems related to homelessness, such as the loss of social support and factors such as that, which are all contributing factors to the high rate of people with serious mental illness who are homeless. Now, you're a psychologist, as we have established, but some, people with serious mental illness never encounters psychologists in their treatment. They're mostly treated by psychiatrists, social workers, and others. Do you want to see more psychologists involved
这导致人们变得依赖残疾项目来维持基本生活。但这些残疾项目很少提供足够的资金让一个人真正能够拥有体面的生活质量。因此，严重精神疾病患者往往生活在贫困中。其它因素也可能导致与无家可归相关的问题，例如社会支持的丧失以及诸如此类的因素，这些都是导致严重精神疾病患者中无家可归率高的促成因素。现在，正如我们所确定的，你是一位心理学家，但一些严重精神疾病患者在治疗中从未遇到过心理学家。他们主要由精神科医生、社会工作者和其它人员治疗。你希望看到更多的心理学家参与
in this aspect of the field? And if so, why? How would that help? Well, you're right that psychologists, in fact, do not have as large a role as they could play in the treatment of people with serious mental illness. In typical community mental health centers, there usually are at least some master's level psychologists who, like master's level social workers, provide many of the psychosocial treatments that have been shown to be effective for people with serious mental illness. This could be intervention such as social skills training, cognitive behavior therapy for psychosis, or training in illness management and recovery. But psychologists as a profession typically have a relatively limited role to play in
到该领域的这一方面吗？如果是这样，为什么？那会有什么帮助？嗯，你说得对，事实上，心理学家在严重精神疾病患者的治疗中并没有发挥他们本可以发挥的作用。在典型的社区心理健康中心，通常至少有一些硕士水平的心理学家，像硕士水平的社会工作者一样，提供许多已被证明对严重精神疾病患者有效的心理社会治疗。这可能是诸如社交技能训练、精神病认知行为疗法或疾病管理与康复训练等干预措施。但心理学家作为一个职业，通常在
the treatment of people with serious mental illness, and yet have potential to play a much bigger role and to be part of the solution of bringing more effective treatments to the SMI population. This is because the training of psychologists uniquely prepares them for working with complex cases of individuals, as people with serious mental illness often are, and who are living in both complex social situations involving family members, communities, and multiple health care providers. So the training of psychologists puts them in a unique position both to lead treatment teams and in particular to coordinate effective psychosocial services to help people with serious mental
严重精神疾病患者的治疗中发挥的作用相对有限，然而他们有潜力发挥更大的作用，并成为为严重精神疾病人群带来更有效治疗方案的解决方案的一部分。这是因为心理学家的培训使他们独特地准备好处理复杂的个人案例，正如严重精神疾病患者通常的情况一样，他们生活在涉及家庭成员、社区和多个医疗保健提供者的复杂社会环境中。因此，心理学家的培训使他们处于独特的地位，既可以领导治疗团队，特别是在协调有效的心理社会服务方面，以帮助严重精神
illness live a more productive and rewarding lives. I want to talk for a minute about two things that are often interrelated. the stigma against people with serious mental illness and violence. One common stereotype is that people with serious mental illness are more likely to commit violent crimes, and this is only reinforced by events like the mass shooting that recently took place in Maine to give just one example. But advocates often point out that people with serious mental illness are more likely to be the victims than the perpetrators of crime. Where does the truth lie? First of all, just to make the connection with stigma, we do know that in the general population,
疾病患者过上更富有成效和更有价值的生活。我想花点时间谈谈两件经常相互关联的事情：针对严重精神疾病患者的污名化和暴力。一个常见的刻板印象是，严重精神疾病患者更有可能犯下暴力罪行，而最近在缅因州发生的大规模枪击事件（仅举一例）进一步强化了这一点。但倡导者经常指出，严重精神疾病患者更有可能是犯罪的受害者，而不是肇事者。真相在哪里？首先，为了与污名化建立联系，我们确实知道在普通人群中，
when you ask people questions about people who have a serious mental illness, many people have negative attitudes and attitudes such as beliefs that the person is incapable of working, incapable of having good social relationships, and of taking care of oneself. And there is a great deal of stigma and even prejudice against people with serious mental illness when it comes to things such as housing, hiring for jobs and things like that. Now, if you want to understand what factors are most strongly predictive of stigma towards people with a mental illness, it turns out that the belief that people with serious mental illness are very prone to violence is the most important predictor of what they're. a person has stigmatizing attitudes. We also know that the most important protective factor against people having stigma is having a relationship with a person who has a serious mental illness. So somebody who's had a family member, a friend, a coworker with a serious mental illness,
当你问人们关于患有严重精神疾病的人的问题时，许多人持有负面态度，例如认为该人没有工作能力、没有建立良好社会关系的能力、没有照顾自己的能力。当涉及到住房、招聘工作等事情时，对严重精神疾病患者存在大量的污名化甚至偏见。现在，如果你想了解哪些因素最强烈地预示着对精神疾病患者的污名化，事实证明，认为严重精神疾病患者非常容易产生暴力行为是导致一个人产生污名化态度的最重要的预测因素。我们还知道，防止人们产生污名化的最重要的保护因素是与患有严重精神疾病的人建立关系。所以，那些有家庭成员、朋友、同事患有严重精神疾病的人，
those individuals by and large have much less stigmatizing attitudes about mental illness. So beliefs or concerns about violence in people with serious mental illness. illness really go to the core of the nature of stigma of mental illness. So you asked about, well, what is the truth about both violence and victimization in people with serious mental illness? So let's talk about victimization first. Victimization is very, very common. We know that childhood victimization, such as physical and sexual abuse, has a significant effect
这些人总体上对精神疾病的污名化态度要少得多。因此，关于严重精神疾病患者暴力行为的信念或担忧，确实触及了精神疾病污名化本质的核心。所以你问，关于严重精神疾病患者的暴力和受害，真相是什么？让我们先谈谈受害。受害是非常、非常普遍的。我们知道，童年受害，如身体和性虐待，对增加个人患严重精神疾病的风险有显著影响。然后我们也知道，在人们患上严重精神疾病后，由于各种原因，他们继续更容易受到伤害。他们可能生活在糟糕的社区，在那里他们更有可能成为犯罪的受害者。他们可能缺乏社会判断力，无法识别他们更容易受到伤害的情况。而且因为他们患有精神疾病，如果他们受到伤害，当他们报告问题时（例如向警察或医疗专业人员报告），他们可能不太会被相信。所以我们知道，在严重精神疾病患者中，受害率非常、非常高。现在让我们转向暴力问题。
on increasing the risk of an individual developing a serious mental illness. And then we also know that after people develop a serious mental illness, they continue to be more at risk for victimization for a variety of reasons. They may live in bad neighborhoods where they're more likely to be victims of crime. They may lack social judgment in terms of being able to identify situations where they're more likely to be victimized. And because they have a mental illness, if they are victimized, they may be less likely to be believed when they report problems. such as to police or people in the medical profession. So we know that victimization is very, very high among people with serious mental illness. So now let's turn to the question of violence.
事实证明，研究表明，患有严重精神疾病确实会使一个人参与某种犯罪（包括可能的暴力犯罪）的几率有非常小但轻微的增加。这种增加是一个相对较小的增加，当一个人在接受治疗时，这种情况会大大减少，因为可以使用的药物以及心理社会治疗可以降低一个人产生暴力行为的几率。因此，虽然一个人产生暴力行为的几率有轻微增加，但严重精神疾病患者产生暴力行为的几率仍然非常低。如果你看他们的终身历史，事实上，他们经历过或正在经历持续受害的几率要大得多。最近关于非自愿承诺或强迫精神疾病患者接受治疗的问题进行了很多讨论，特别是那些无家可归的人。这最近在加利福尼亚州和纽约市的新闻中出现。
It turns out that the research shows that having a severe mental illness has a very small, but it does have a slight increase in the chances of the person engaging in some kind of a crime, including a possible violent crime. This increase is a relatively small increase, and it's something that is greatly reduced when a person is in treatment, because the medications that can be used, as well as psychosocial treatments, can lower the chances of a person being violent. So, although there is a slight increase in the chances of somebody being violent, the chances are still really quite low that a person with serious mental illness will be violent. And if you look at their lifetime history, the chances are, in fact, much greater that they will have experienced or do experience ongoing victimization. There's been a lot of discussion recently around the issue of involuntary commitment or forcing people with mental illness into treatment, especially people who are unhoused. And this has been in the news recently in California and New York City.
研究对此有什么说法（如果有的话）？非自愿承诺是让人们接受治疗的有效方法吗？它有效吗？所以非自愿治疗的问题需要分解为两个层面的非自愿治疗。一种是非自愿治疗，当该人对自己或他人构成严重风险时。另一种是针对那些可能缺乏对患有精神疾病的认识，但不一定构成
What does the research say on this, if anything, is involuntary commitment and a fact that? effective way to get people treatment, does it work? So the question of involuntary treatment needs to be broken down into two levels of involuntary treatment. There is involuntary treatment when the person is presenting a grave risk to themselves or to other people. And then there is involuntary treatment for people who perhaps lack awareness into having a psychiatric illness, but are not necessarily presenting a psychiatric illness.
对自己或他人构成严重威胁的人的非自愿治疗。对于那些对自己或他人构成严重风险的人，非自愿承诺有明确的作用。在保护社会以及保护人们免受自身伤害方面，这是一种实际的必要性。目前的法律基本上支持
a grave threat to themselves or to other people. There is a clear role to play for involuntary commitment for people who are presenting a grave risk to themselves or to other people. And this is a practical necessity in terms of the protection of society as well as the protection of people against themselves. And the current laws essentially support
这种类型的非自愿治疗，在整个美国以及世界大部分地区也是如此。在没有对自己或他人构成严重危险的历史的情况下，将某人非自愿地承诺（例如门诊治疗）的问题是一个更复杂的问题。没有研究表明非自愿门诊治疗有效。事实上，这是一种极具争议的方法，因为它本质上涉及剥夺个人选择他们想要接受什么样的治疗和过什么样的生活的公民权利。缺乏证据表明非自愿门诊治疗实际上改善了严重精神疾病患者的长期结果。
this type of involuntary treatment throughout the entire United and throughout most of the world as well. The question of whether involuntarily committing somebody, say, to outpatient treatment, in the absence of a history of presenting a grave danger to themselves or to other people, is a more complex one. There is research that does not show that involuntary outpatient treatment helps. And in fact, it is a highly controversial approach because essentially it involves taking away the civil rights of an individual to choose what kind of treatments and what kind of lives they want to live. There is a lack of evidence showing that involuntary outpatient treatment actually improves the long-term outcomes of individuals with a serious mental illness.
它还存在将治疗提供者变成监护人的问题，或者实际上不得不监控个人参与治疗的情况，不是为了他们自己的利益，而是因为某种法院命令或某种保护令。因此，在这一点上，非自愿门诊治疗的作用仍有待实证确定。事实上，你可以争辩说，研究表明它不起作用。因此，增加非自愿门诊承诺的努力是有问题的，因为它们干涉了严重精神疾病患者的基本公民权利。这些公民权利是指在不对自己或他人构成严重危险的情况下，就自己的治疗做出自己的决定。所以我只想最后问一下，我们在政策层面上可以做些什么来改善严重精神疾病患者的治疗和护理。
It also has the problem of turning the treatment providers into guardians, or in effect having to monitor an individual's participation in treatment, not for their own good, but rather because of a kind of a court order or some type of a protective order. So at this point, the role of involuntary outpatient treatment remains to be established empirically. In fact, you can argue that the research indicates that it does not work. And therefore, efforts to increase involuntary outpatient commitment are problematic in that they interfere with the basic civil rights of people with the serious mental illness. Those civil rights being to make their own decisions regarding their own treatment in the absence of presenting a grave danger to themselves or to other people. So I just want to wrap up by asking what we could be doing on a policy level to improve the treatment and care for people with serious mental illness.
它还存在一个问题，即把治疗提供者变成了监护人，或者实际上不得不去监督个人对治疗的参与，这并非为了他们自身的好处，而是因为某种法院命令或某种保护令。因此，在这一点上，非自愿门诊治疗的作用仍有待实证研究来确定。事实上，你可以认为研究表明它并不奏效。因此，增加非自愿门诊强制治疗的努力是有问题的，因为它们干涉了严重精神疾病患者的基本公民权利。这些公民权利是指在不对自己或他人构成严重危险的情况下，有权就自己的治疗做出决定。所以，我想最后问一下，我们在政策层面可以做些什么来改善对严重精神疾病患者的治疗和护理。
Well, there's a variety of different kinds of policy improvements, certainly that could be done. One way of improving long-term outcomes would be to make the funding of a broader range of evidence-based practices more routinely available. to individuals with a serious mental illness. I can take one particular practice as an example. This is the individual placement and support called IPS model of supported employment. Supported employment is an approach to helping people get and keep competitive jobs that places a priority on rapid job search to help people find jobs related to their areas of interest and then providing the ongoing supports in order to keep these jobs.
当然，我们可以进行各种各样的政策改进。改善长期结果的一种方法是，让患有严重精神疾病的个人能够更常规地获得更广泛的循证实践资助。我可以举一个具体的例子，这就是所谓的IPS支持性就业模式，即个人安置与支持模式。支持性就业是一种帮助人们获得并保持竞争性工作的途径，它优先考虑快速求职，以帮助人们找到与他们兴趣领域相关的工作，然后提供持续的支持以保持这些工作。
There are over 25 randomized controlled trials showing that supported employment programs based on the IPS model are more effective than any other vocational rehabilitation approach to helping people get and keep competitive jobs. And we've already discussed how getting and keeping competitive work can both improve financial, standing and reduce risk of relapse and re-hospitalization. In addition, getting work can be destigmatizing because other people see that the individual with serious mental illness is capable of working and contributing to society. And yet, despite this, throughout the United States, most states lack a central funding mechanism for funding IPS supported employment. And In fact, the funding difficulties with this intervention continue in the majority of states
有超过25项随机对照试验表明，基于IPS模式的支持性就业项目在帮助人们获得并保持竞争性工作方面，比任何其他职业康复方法都更有效。我们已经讨论过，获得并保持竞争性工作既能改善经济状况，又能降低复发和再次住院的风险。此外，获得工作可以消除污名化，因为其他人会看到患有严重精神疾病的个人有能力工作并为社会做出贡献。然而，尽管如此，在美国各地，大多数州都缺乏资助IPS支持性就业的中央资金机制。事实上，这种干预措施的资金困难在当今美国的大多数州仍然存在。
in the U.S. today. And so this is an example of where there's a need for review or revision of policies supporting mental health services in order to support the wide-scale implementation of an evidence-based practice for improving employment outcomes in people with serious mental illness. Dr. Mucera, I want to thank you for joining me. I think you have dispelled some of the myths about people with serious mental illness. I really appreciate that. Kim, it's been a delight to be here. I have really enjoyed talking with you and to spread the good word about how much progress we have made in the treatment of serious mental illnesses. Absolutely. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on our website or on
因此，这是一个需要审查或修订支持心理健康服务政策的例子，以便支持大规模实施循证实践，从而改善严重精神疾病患者的就业成果。Mucera博士，我想感谢您加入我的节目。我认为您消除了一些关于严重精神疾病患者的误解。我非常感激。Kim，很高兴能来到这里。我真的很喜欢与您交谈，并传播关于我们在治疗严重精神疾病方面取得多大进展的好消息。当然。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站www.combeckycology.org或我们的网站上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，或者在
Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple、Spotify、YouTube或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Kondyenne。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。